[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar hi content phenotypic screening
answering questions you haven't even
asked yet
i am marie stone of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by molecular devices to learn more
visit
moleculardevices.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speakers dr
angeline lim senior application
scientist at molecular devices and dr
victor wong chief scientific officer at
core life analytics
angeline and victor you may now begin
your presentation
hello and welcome to the webinar my name
is anjalin lim and i'm a senior imaging
application scientist at molecular
devices
today's webinar is divided into two
parts and i'll start off with an
introduction to high content phenotypic
essay specifically focused on cell
painting
now because such high content essays
tend to generate lots of data in the
second half of the webinar victor wong
from qualified analytics will tell us
how we can work with such big data
so to get things started i'm going to
kick up this presentation with an
introduction to cell painting
so what is cell painting
this is a phenotypic image-based
profiling method that has widespread
applications and drug discovery and also
to functional and also in functional
genomic studies
it was initially developed and optimized
at the broad institute and carpenters
lab and the aim of cell painting is to
visually represent as much of the cell
as possible and so to do this this essay
is therefore highly multiplex cells are
stained with multiple fluorescent dyes
and for cell painting you would do that
with up to six fluorescent dyes to label
various compartments in the cell
the images are then used to generate an
information rich morphological profile
which characterizes each cell
now i'll also like to take some time to
to explain the difference between
phenotypic screening versus phenotypic
profiling
just to give an idea of how powerful
profiling is
so with screening you would typically
quantify a few features
and these features are selected based on
some known association with the biology
when it comes to profiling the idea is
to quantify everything
and so all the measurements that you get
form a so-called fingerprint that
represents the cell biological state
and as i've heard before in other talks
there's someone who said
in profiling you would measure
everything and ask questions later
and so here's a simple illustration that
shows compounds
that compounds a and b have a similar
phenotypic fingerprint and are both
quite different from the effects of
compound c on cells
in addition profiling is also an
unbiased approach and when you take an
unbiased approach in your experiment it
increases the possibility of making some
novel discoveries since it is not
limited by some prior knowledge
it is also more efficient because a
single experiment can be mined for other
for other questions that you may have
later
and so let's say for example that in the
last couple of slides i have gotten
everyone in the audience very excited
about cell painting and you just want to
get started so how does one go about
carrying out cell painting
so in a standard cell painting essay
cells are perturbed using chemical or
genetic approaches they are then fixed
stain and image in a high content imager
so that's step one all the way through
four
and then this is then followed by
image analysis step five here and then
with some data analysis involved now
most biologists or cell biologists are
very familiar with the with the markers
that's used in the cell painting essay
and also the protocol involved in the
first half of the the
workflow
however many are not trained to handle
and analyze the large volumes of data
that you generally get from these
experiments
so typically one would have to rely on
collaborations with some in-house data
science experts to carry out data
analytics and then come up with some
interpretation of the experiment
and so here what i want to do there is
to present a complete workflow where one
can independently complete a cell
painting essay from start to finish
we set up a simple cell painting essay
to demonstrate how you can carry out the
workflow flow from start to finish
so u2 os cells were seeded in 3d foil
plate
and 11 different compounds were tested
at 7 concentrations and this was done in
quadruplicate
this table here shows the dyes that were
used and the cellular compartments that
they label and also the filter sets
that's used to detect these compartments
now i want to draw your attention to the
golgi and actin filament over here now
in the standard cell painting assay the
image acquisition for these two
structures are captured with the same
filter set that's with texas red now
these two different structures can then
be later resolved in the image analysis
step if
required however here we
we modified the cell painting assay by
making use of the alexa floor 750 to
label the actin filament instead and
then acquire images using the size 7
filter set
in this way we can acquire and get more
robust analysis of actin that's
independent of the golgi staining or we
can also in other words you can also get
more robust analysis of golgi
independent of actin and we were able to
do this using the image express confocal
ht.ai
this instrument uses a laser light
source and is capable of imaging up to
eight channels which makes this imager
highly suitable for multiplex or highly
modified applications such as cell
painting
this figure on the right shows the
spectral characteristics of the laser
light source and the detection of the
different cell compartments are also
indicated
so here are images acquired using this
modified protocol where we have actin
and they're
captured in a size 7 channel these are
the various organelles or compartments
that's labeled with the dyes so again
now enjoy attention to golgi and that's
the actin filament
now here is an image that was
here images that was acquired using a
standard cell painting assay and so if
we were to look at just the actin golgi
channel you can see the actin filaments
quite clearly but the golgi pancte or
you know all the goji structures are a
little bit hard to make out
so here are comparison images from the
texas red filter set
using the standard cell painting assay
and the modified cell painting assay
on the left you're looking at golgi and
actin there are images in the same
channel and on the right this is just
golgi and you can see there's a huge
dramatic difference between the left and
the right and this is in chloroquine
treated cells because and the treated
cells the the the increase in number of
golgi puncture is a lot more dramatic
a couple more example images for
comparison and you can see in some cases
that again with treatment there is a lot
more golgi pante and so this increased
number of goji you can imagine could be
masked by the actin
by the actin structures if they were
both image using the same acquisition
channel
so this shows that using separate
imaging channels for the golgi and
cytoskeleton could increase the
sensitivity of the cell painting assay
and more robustly represent the cellular
phenotypic profiles
the next step in the workflow is image
analysis
here i use the encarta image analysis
software
this software provides measurements that
are important for phenotypic profiling
and they include
spatial measurements and this refers to
measurements or numbers that refer to
the shape the size diameter etc
it also gives you intensity measurements
texture and also context contextual
features such as the spatial
distribution of organelles and their
relationship to each other
now to add a little bit here and carter
also comes with the deep learning based
segmentation tool that allows one to get
more robust segmentation that is based
on models built with training images it
also comes with some pre-trained models
and one of them is the nuclei model
which i've used to identify and segment
the nuclei in the cell painting assay
so shown here in the middle panel is an
example of some of the extracted
features after image analysis
here's a screenshot of this software
again the image analysis setup is very
user friendly and easy to use
shown here example images with a feature
mask overlay from the encounter software
so from here about
487 features were extracted per cell and
so you can imagine that with all of
these numbers and from every cell you
need to be able to have some kind of
tool to make sense of all of these
numbers and so with that the next part
of the workflow we have to do some data
analytics
so measurements from the encarta
software were uploaded into strata miner
platform and so when i first started
working on cell painting i was initially
stuck at this part over here because i
was suddenly faced with so many numbers
and i didn't know what to do with that
and then i found the strata minor
platform which is a cloud-based data
analytics software that you can use for
further data analytics now victor will
go into details of the workflow in the
later part of this webinar but very
briefly i will walk you through what i
did
so the data was uploaded
and then it was the features were
normalized and this was followed by data
reduction and in my case over here i use
principal component analysis
the components were then used to
calculate the distance score
which is then used for hit selection and
cluster analysis
for the next couple of slides i will
just show some highlights of the kind of
data or
of the kind of output we get from the
stratominer platform
so one of the steps in the workflow is
hit selection which is very relevant
because one of the questions we
typically ask in every experiment is
whether the treatment effect we give
produced any significant effect at all
so in this case for this experiment the
question would ask is which compound
treatment gave us a significant
phenotypic effect compared to the
control
and this can be done with visual
inspection we can pick up compounds that
have very strong effects on the cell in
this way so comparing control and the
positive control you can see obviously
these two look very different
cccp treated cells also look very
different
however when we look at repromising
treated cell that's when you may stop a
little bit and go i'm not sure if this
is significantly different or not
and so a visual inspection
you can use that to to pick up cells
that show a dramatic
difference compared to the control but
then when it comes to more subtle
effects that would be difficult to pick
up visually
in addition just visual inspection is
also not a practical approach because
when you have hundreds of whales each
with multiple images captured in
different channels it's extremely
difficult to go through all of them
and so what is the workaround or what is
the solution to this
so prior to hit selection the data was
reduced using principal component
analysis
and in hit picking these calculated
factor scores are used to identify
significant outliers and this is this is
being represented as a metric that's
referred to as the distance score the
distance score is used to represent the
phenotypic effect of treated cells
compared to control cells
and shown here is a scatter plot of the
distance score for the plate
the color coding here represents the
control versus the treated groups
and in red
the red represents the control the
control wells and the color the color
bars represent
the treated the treated group
and so one observation you may see is
that there is a large spread in my data
point but this is because each of my
compounds were tested in a seven point
dilution series and so this explains why
there is a spread
and because the compounds were used at
different concentrations i was able i
was also able to get a dose response
curve based on the phenotypic distance
score
hierarchical clustering can also be
performed on a statistically significant
hit based on the selected parameters or
calculated factors
now clustering would group your cells
with similar phenotypic profiles
together
shown here is a dendrogram that
represents the hierarchical relationship
between all the significant compounds
there are 10 clusters over here and each
are represented by these colored bars
here
now most clusters are made of one
compound treatment for example where i'm
pointing to right now this these pink
bars
are all in one cluster and they're made
up of only cccp treated cells
next to it is a star respawning cluster
and then next to the star sparring
cluster in yellow and this is a cluster
that's made of latranculin however there
are also some clusters that are made up
of different compounds
such as over here textile and rotanine
to tendrion chloroquine
cytocalatin d and latranculin
so what does this mean
so one of the ways clustering can be
useful is that you can use it to
identify compounds that have similar
mechanisms of actions
and therefore for example if you have a
novel compound and you don't know very
much about it and this novel compound is
clustered with a group that is made up
of
compounds that have a specific kinase
inhibitor as a mechanism of action for
example you can use that as information
to design future experiments
to to figure out what the mechanism
action is for this novel compound
and so just to illustrate some example
this this first cluster over here is
made up of
cells that were treated with titandrine
and chloroquine
these two compounds are known to have
effects in the autophagy pathway
and although i don't have a specific
marker for other other phagic vesicles
in in the cell paint assay we can see
that there are similarities in the
phenotypes of these two cells of these
two groups of cells for example you can
see it there is an increased number of
these goji pancake vesicles
of the goji vesicles
and there's also an increase in the in
in the er channel which is represented
in green over here between these two
another example i'm going to show is
this cluster that is next to the blue
cluster
this green cluster is made up of
latranculin and cytokinesis and d
treated groups
now these two compounds are known
inhibitors of actin polymerization
and so we can definitely see that there
are similarities between these two
images
cytokinesis d and also the tranquiline
is known to inhibit cytokinesis and so
one of the hallmarks of such inhibition
of cytokinesis is the presence of
multinucleated cells and you can see
this represented in both of these images
and so to sum up
to sum up i would like to recap on some
of the main points from this part of the
presentation
i hope i've convinced you that
phenotypic profiling is a simple yet
powerful image-based tool that has
diverse applications
the workflow that i've shown is easy to
implement you just need a high content
imager image analysis software and data
analytics software now most high content
imager come with analysis software or
you could use any of the freeware open
source freeware available
and because as a cell biologist by
training the bottleneck for me really
wasn't data analytics i was very happy
to partner with strata miner to be able
to use that platform to help me
interpret all that data i'm getting from
my cell painting essay
and last but not least i would like to
acknowledge the my following co-workers
at molecular devices
offered a very useful discussion and
help along the way and of course as i've
mentioned to call live analytics to
david and victor both of whom have been
very helpful in answering
my many questions and also for many
useful discussions
and with that i'm going to stop here
thank you all for your time and i'm
going to pass this presentation over to
victor now
thank you angeline for the lovely talk
covering high concern philosophy
screening using self-printing approaches
but for my partner i'll continue with
that show you to cover the questions
that you've not considered
or perhaps even a phrase
more specifically
i will address the issue of how to work
with big data this talk is emphasized
how to turn engineers wonderful images
of cells into biologically meaningful
information
you will not be heavy on the technical
aspects
providers emphasis
is really more on the fundamentals of
analyzing and playing with the data at
the end of the workflow that angeline
showed earlier
essentially
how did we get from acquiring these
beautiful images from steps one to five
to the finish line except 67 with new
meaningful biological knowledge
when it comes down to high content
screening
the data that you get after image
analysis is not quite the simple case of
clocking in formulas
reformating your data
as you typically would eat in excel or
graphicism
predominantly because of the volume of
numerical values that insulin had
extracted from the image analysis
software
her supplementation process
extracted 250 different measurements and
this table here of numerical values
only shows a small part of the 250
species spanning across the table here
and beyond
going down the columns are the rares or
objects and i believe engineering
extracts the species at the opposite
level of resolution
this is why the output can be quite
overwhelming in terms of comprehension
but with the right analytics workflows
like sweater manual
you can handle them very rapidly and
easily
so how did angeline get from here with
all these numerical values in our data
to serve with all the wonderful
visualizations of the data
so how do we get from a to b
as shown in the previous slide
from numerous values in the data sets to
produce biological development knowledge
from the data set
but there are key things to keep in mind
for successful multi-parametric data
analysis and that is to make sure
that you have a consistent
workflow
workflows that goes all over the map
deviating from the sony makes it very
difficult to reproduce
and this is particularly true if you
have everyone in the lab analyzing big
data in their own way
using various python or packages
but as an example from our stratomania
data analytics platform you follow this
general workflow
which not only allow accessibility of
data
but you ensure reproducibility as well
as transparency of your analysis
additionally you must also be able to
simplify your data
to make
relationships training more humanly
understandable
i'll go into more detail on this point
later
lastly but also the analysis workflow
must be iterative so that the new
biology has been discovered
of course there
are new questions about it
so it's important that your analysis
allows you to go back with the new
information on hand
and re-analyze the data from a new
perspective
and in this workflow that i will go over
today includes assessing the raw data
elimination
redundancy in your data set
basically
simplifying your data
quality control
removing bias in your data sets
through data reduction and a historical
and question
so let's dive right into this workflow i
was talking about in a little bit more
detail
first of all
big data outputs from high content
screening like insulins are typically
investing for mass with karma or top
separator files
these are usually large in size that can
go up to 10 such gigabytes with hundreds
and hundreds of rows and columns of
numerical values and therefore you won't
be able to open these files in excel or
other species
while this may seem trivial to you now
but when it comes down to it this is the
first thing that you have to do so you
need to have a platform like
shutterminer that can accept large data
files quickly for you to analyze your
data
so after when you've uploaded your data
there's still a few things that you need
to do
remember that when i mentioned earlier
that it's important you have to simplify
the data
of one of the ways to simplify your data
set is to be able to detect good data
from the bad error
this means that you need to eliminate
features that are deemed unusual or not
useful
what do we mean by not useful
this means measurements and species that
contain non-numerical values
this that they disagree
that there is no variation
with excessive missing data its high
mass prison correlation value
that the uniform distribution in that
particular feature
so it is important to check out the
garbage and thereby reducing the
computational time and energy you carry
out the rest of the analysis
now again
i want to emphasize the consistency
in your data analysis workflow as well
as detecting these redundant features
it's key here
so this command reapplies robustly over
and over again
to remove additional redundancy as you
add more and more phenotypic statuses
now in smaller manner we have failed
precisely that
a sequential and logical step that is
similar to to the list here to detect
and to eliminate redundant measurements
so instead of mono it will detect
whether or not the data is binary or
continuous
anything that is binary would be
considered to be redundant
how many unique data points that you
have in the measurement is also
another obvious criteria
especially if you have less than three
unique values
that that feature is probably telling
you nothing interesting
and if you have a standard deviation
it's another one that indicates the
variation of your thesis if it's too low
you'll be automatically flat
and if you have a high maximum
correlation value meaning that you have
two or more measurements that are
highly correlated with each other
that one or more of these features are
considered to be redundant
after all
why would you consider multiple features
that measures
the same thing
after removing the redundancies of data
it's also critical to be able to create
a plate map for your experiment
where you can assign specific ways to
use treatment groups for example where
the negative and positive controls are
and where the compounds of interest are
located
this extra layer of metadata information
will be useful downstream of the
analysis process where you can check
things as you go through the data
analysis workflow
this plate map here is associated with
insulin cell printing experiments which
unlabeled her negative and positive
controls
as well as some of the components that
she's interested in comparing all the
other samples would say for example
a call queen or last triangulum
b but after creating the plate map
which follows then that you'd like to
see a quick overview of the data
virtually and interactively
and it's important that you are able to
visualize
to see
how your data is being distributed
based on the various x and
x and y axis
and interactively to the point where you
can select data points and remove some
of the obvious outliers
and or assign
a cluster of interesting data points
to
to create a new relation classes or
groups
and this is particularly important for a
number of reasons and this all points to
one thing
quality control
associated elaborate
on this a little bit further
quality control is important because it
makes absolutely no sense to do high
content screening
especially when you're at the essay
development series
and it takes you many months or even
years to analyze the data only to find
out at the end that your controllers are
not working like they should for example
they need to fix too late
because already a vast amount of time
and resources have been spent
so having an analytical workflow
that includes quality control built into
you through the process will allow you
to rapidly access the essay and this is
tremendously important especially seeing
how well segregated your
negative and positive controls are
and thereby allowing you to calculate
something like a c factor
you see how good of an essay you have or
whether your controllers are given the
phenotypes as destructive
the higher the c factor the better the
essay is this is just one example the
plenty of mathematical approaches that
can allow you to access the quality of
your essay
when you're dealing with multiple places
in your high content screens you need to
be able to normalize the data and why is
that because there is a hidden impact of
play uniformity
as indicated in the essay guidance
manual
it says that face-to-face variation
involves signals that induce the
appearance of significant misplanned
radiation when in fact that there is
little variation in signals properly
normalized the old space controls
the goal of place to place mobilization
is to move
or took into the occult
place and as effects
as you have advised the comparison of
well x versus where y in place number
three
and if you want to know more about how
to do a good screen
the essay guidance manual is a great
resource and a great place to start
it's developed by the nih but is
practically the bible for any essay
development including high content
apprentices i urge you to also check out
the workshop that is available online
and enjoy the great weather information
on the basics and the good practices to
consider
and here
is such an example of the 15th place
from one of the phenotypic streams where
you can quickly see that there are bags
of place defense
but when you normalize all of that to
say the median of the negative controls
you effectively remove these
face-to-face variations
then if you're making use of multiple
exact features or measurements
however there are some mathematical
assumptions that need to be met
and that's what data transformation is
about but the math commonly used in
phenotypic data analysis there is the
assumption that your measurements or
pieces are normally distributed
if they're positively or negatively
issues you can transform them back
towards a more normal distribution
this is critical to remove fires through
species that are heavily skewed in the
negative or positive direction
there is an additional step to remove
bias in your data set and that is to
scale your features
because measurements can have very
different scales on numerical ways
think of measuring lens in millimeters
versus kilometers you need to
standardize that
in multivariate analysis measurements
that produce large numbers can have more
influence than those with small numbers
if that introduced bias in your data set
so you need to essentially
level the field across all of the
species that you've extracted
steady scaling helps to take care of
this problem
this is also important for machine
learning algorithms to calculate
distances between the numbers
but here is a whole bunch of features
from angeline dataset as you can see the
raw data appears
the excesses of the features see exactly
when the y-axis is in numerical range
some of the measurements that she has
can be up here in the tens of thousands
and this will overwhelm the ones down
here
one thing then you can do is to relate
every set of points to the standard
deviation
of the distribution for that measurement
this generates what is known as the
c-score
now you can see how the scales are much
more similar
a better way to do this is to use what's
known as the robust z-score which is
less sensitive to extreme outliers
what happens when you have missing data
in your data set
and taking care of missing values is a
dirty little secret of data science
if you have a hole in your data dataset
of your matrix you can cross many of the
algorithms that you'll be using for
dimensionality reduction or machine
learning
and of course it's not valid you just
put a zero
in there as a substitute for the missing
later
for this reason we tried to figure out
what values should be there
we're not going through too much details
in this webinar but there are many forms
of regression or even machine learning
approaches that can be used for this
purpose
and in certain models we have a very
simple method that uses the values of
other replicas
that you have values but perhaps the
median of all the values for that
measurement
the end result should never change the
overall variation in your dataset for
that measurement
the worst thing that could happen
is that you get a false negative for
that particular feature
high content screening
often used high in multiple domestic
measurements
and essential to reduce the dimensions
of the data
but this means that you're compressing
the data from the high to low dimension
of space without losing the original
information
why this is important is due to the
course of dimensionality
which means that if you have too many
pieces
there is less accuracy for
classification purposes
and by performing data reduction
you remove additional redundancies in
your data set
and by having less dimensions it's good
for faster analysis
and make it more compatible with
algorithms that are unsuitable for high
dimensional data
and then
you can easily and rapidly access the
data by looking at what groups of
species are giving you a similar
or different story
so by performing data reduction of
principal component analysis or common
factor analysis
could also use important insights into
which features
or measurements comes out the most
phenotypically speaking
and then you can quickly explore the
variation of the data in each component
or factor
this is extremely helpful in giving
biological meanings to
non-interesting species and therefore
this step is critical
for basically seeing the biology coming
out of your dataset
but after all that's certainly done
you can take that and take your data to
find out which compounds or histogenic
phenotypes produces you specifically
asian class and this can be a group of
compounds or a negative control
for example
here's the hit visualization that
engineering has shown earlier
with a simple case to find hits from the
samples that are phenotypically
different from the negative controls
the metrics to measure fast phenotypic
differences
is the euclidean distance score that
basically calculates how far are these
samples from the negative controls
okay and so this helps you identify
compounds of interest
as each compound apparently results in a
very different style of phenotypes
moreover
you can also find hits or phenotypically
similar to say the positive controls as
well so there's a lot of flexibility
to play with
moreover i won't go into too much
details here but
there is an attractive thing about high
content training in the mission is that
it's very amenable to machine learning
and the use of artificial intelligence
and this is already being implemented in
sodomiano's recognized phenotypes of
insects
the development of this ai model can
then be used to apply to your growing
number of images generated
where you can find hits based on the
parameters that you set
as a matter of fact
deep learning can take yourself even
further
by applying training models to carry out
automated segmentation
visual suction
and data mining to find the hist of
interest
what is also useful to include in your
data analysis workflow
that can really enrich your knowledge
from your data is to be able to take
those hits that i've shown you in the
previous slide
and incorporate additional information
about the different concentrations of
those hidden compounds you can then
generate those response curves this is
very informative for any stroke
discovery pipelines where you can
quickly see not only the hist of
interest but also how they illustrate
phenotypic response in
those dependent fashion for example here
one of the heads that insulin had
was a cctp
and sort of mono can extract
concentration information that is in the
metadata
to generate this ic50 occurs based on
distance scores
the images from engineering cell phone
single points can then be added on
to verify and visualize the phenotypic
effects which is extremely obvious
lastly but not released
it is useful to be able to take the
information from your history step
and plot them into a clustering graph
for instance here again shown by
angeline earlier to cluster all of her
hits
using heraldical clustering
based on phenotypic similarities across
all the components similarly in the
dimensionality reduction set
here you can obviously see some of the
compounds of clusters together that make
total sense
but when you already see other compounds
being clustered together for example
chloroquine and saturation
indicating possible similar mechanisms
of action to achieve the same phenotypic
outcome
between the two compounds
so to summarize when you develop your
high content data analysis workflow
you need to consider these three points
here to ensure the robustness of your
analysis pipeline
and i cannot emphasize enough
by having a robust workflow like we have
in certain minors that it can go all
over the place
and it will pay off enormously at the
end by keeping your data analysis
straight and error
and with this workflow you know having
huge amounts of data from high content
screens is no longer something to be
afraid of or to be intimidated by
because with this workflow now you can
make your data and your data analysis
accessible reproducible simple
vegetarian
ancient plants
so this is how you can
successfully get from a
with beautiful message coming out of
high content
imaging instrument to be
where you can visualize the data and
analyze them quickly and intuitively
to discover new knowledge from the data
um so yeah thank you very much for your
attention and we hope this webinar is
informative
and help answer the questions that you
have not asked yet
and more importantly that we hope
that this webinar excites you to use um
self-printing approaches with robust
data analysis workflows to accelerate
your scientific discovery pipelines
i'd like to extend my gratitude to my
colleagues at molecular device
engineering and using
and the core life analytics david and
meenan who are the co-founders of strata
minor data analysis platform and my
students
to you the audience if you have any
questions or concerns please don't be
shy we're looking forward to hear from
you
thank you
thank you angeline and victor for your
informative presentations
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
so let's get started our first question
is
do you have to use confocal imaging for
cell painting and what about wide
field microscopy
um i think i can pick up on that one um
you can use confocal imaging if you want
to but um
but there are better ways to accelerate
the immersion process because if you
used to convoke traditional confocal
imaging
then
you have to take pictures one at a time
but with the hair content imaging uh
instruments that's gonna
provided by
medical devices
you can accelerate that process by
adding the automation behind
the
image acquisition uh am i right on that
insulin
um yes you're correct
so you can use either confocal or white
fuel microscopy to do cell painting in
fact one of the first papers
from an carpenter's lab was done on a
white fuel imager
all right thank you
next question
regarding the image analysis how long
does it take to analyze a plate
um let me let me answer that question so
for the initial image analysis part of
the workflow
and the encarta software you can take
about three hours to analyze a 384 well
plate that's you know image with six
channels and four sites per well
the time changes depending on how
complex and how many steps you want to
add into your analysis protocol so for
example if you use a lot of deep
learning models that will take more time
and regarding the um the strata minor
software
that also depends on the the granularity
of the of the data so if it's either
captured at the object level
single cell level field level or
well resolution
usually uh within an hour
you can you can analyze hundreds of
plates at the
well level uh and at field level
and usually at single cell level
depending on how large the data is so
number plates and number of features
and number of cells per well um
yeah
it can take up to a few hours if you get
into the uh
let's say tens or hundreds of pages
all right
thank you
next question
how long does this
approach take to analyze an average
experiment from beginning to end
um let's see i
from beginning to end an average
experiment
so
it's going to start with the the bench
work that will take a few days just to
get experiments set up and once you
acquire the images
you know and if you're familiar with
your workflow already i'm you can get it
done within a day i would say
you know maybe um
wienen or victor would have a something
to add on over here
okay i i i think it's it's mostly on the
on the wet lab stuff and on the uh
on the uh the roboting
pipetting slash
image analysis stuff that's uh that's
the majority of the
of the time that it takes uh i think
especially on the
the bench and wet lab stuff that that's
yeah to my knowledge the the most time
intensive
uh tasks that that need to be done in
order to uh
yeah get to the whole workflow of uh
from the beginning to the uh to the end
uh i think the uh
the real data analysis part um
uh
yeah
if you know exactly what you're looking
for of course then
uh
you can you can done as quickly as a
half an hour but if you're
if you're wanting to inspect all kinds
of different quality metrics uh try out
different normalization methods and
act in a very explorative manner which
some of you guys might do then
then it then of course can
yeah keep you uh keep you busy for weeks
if you're
not sure what your um
what you what you'd like to find um
so that that also yeah really depends on
your the way
you're you're doing your analysis
i hope that that helps
all right thank you
next question
what is the learning curve like and what
are some of the skills needed to start
using it
maybe i can go first since i was
completely new to this when i started um
you don't
well at least you use the strata minor
portion you don't need any programming
skills and knowledge
it was quite easy to get started
in my just my personal experience
right victor vinon um
yeah i want to add to that um in regards
to
like
getting started to
uh to use the high content approaches uh
when i was a postdoc before joining for
life and the lifter i was involved in
actually starting up this whole process
of uh high content philosophy training
approach to find compounds of interest
when you're saying and i must say that
the learning curve can be quite steep
but as long as you have the concept and
the and the uh
foundation
in terms of knowing which markers and
knowing how to validate and optimize
your essays and this is why i strongly
recommend anyone you know who wants to
know more about uh high context trading
go to the essay guidance manual provided
by the nih to great resource and it's
actually workout research uh up and
running the high context we didn't go
over there
and in regards to the data analysis uh
yeah i mean
we developed this platform with that
request workflow
so that you don't need to know program
materials as long as you have
foundations in statistical analysis and
things that you would normally do in the
lab
then you
you can you can do this and there's
nothing to be
intimidated by or be afraid of
yeah yeah i think victor has a very good
point there and i think i'm i'm the
worst
person in the world that
can or can cannot say
that that strata minor
is is easy to uh to use or not because
yeah i
um for a large portion develop this
software myself
in the early days
and and yeah next to that also victor
has been uh
working on a manual that is integrated
in in the software in the in the next
version
so then it will be really easy
for the
let's say the step where you are at that
moment so let's say the the qc part
then you can
pick your brain in in in the manual and
then see
exactly what you can do there and how
you
uh should be able to uh to do that and
uh in addition to that um we're also
together with uh
david egan
my co-founder and and some other
uh
great researchers
were i think already busy for the last
three years of rewriting um
the essay guidance manual um
so there will be a new version released
but i i'm not sure when
that that will happen but uh we're also
yeah uh busy on the writing that and uh
who knows
when that will uh well when that new
version will be published
all right thank you next question
what are the computer tech requirements
for the image and data analysis
um so i can talk about the
image analysis part of it
you know i analyze the data on a
standard
imaging workstation it's not it's not
any super computing
[Music]
device that we have for that so i would
say like
it's got a certain number of cores that
you need to run analysis but i think any
typical image analysis workstation will
work
and um oh sorry go ahead
oh no it's okay um i just want to add on
top of that is that for these types of
data analysis things that it's so much
of a functional computer in terms of
like a working laptop you can you can
run your own data analysis to a file or
you can use our strata mining platform
and
and i want to emphasize that you know
the difference is is that without trying
to write a platform you can do it on a
class um on a cloud
environment and it's wrong with you have
an internet
connection you can access it anywhere
and it's critical in that regard because
then
um
you know if
if your lab mates or your colleagues is
somewhere and they want to access
your analysis then you'll be able to do
that as well as use internet connection
in regards to like you know working your
own laptop and
and looking in your python scripture all
for women what have you uh you just have
to you know
uh make sure that everyone has access to
your analysis to
to choose what you've done and so uh
there's no real specific
computational requirements or
or anything of that kind
yeah i have recently received
that
recommended specs for running synap for
instance
i can share that if you guys are
interested in that
all right thank you
and it looks like we have time for one
more question
in addition to the dies you mentioned is
the cell painting protocol amendable
compatible
with additional markers of interest say
sox9 if i want to oscillate isolate that
specific sox9 positive or sox9 negative
cell populations and compare between the
two
yes you can use additional dyes
again because the
at least the imager that we have has
eight imaging has eight channels and so
you have room to add on more dyes
um but do take note of potential bleed
through a spectral overlap in this case
so make sure you optimize
your antibody or your dye staining
um i mean you can also in instead of
adding more dyes you could also swap out
dyes so you the cell painting protocol
is very adaptable to your specific needs
um
yeah and then in this case you could
also then in the image analysis step
identify cells that have the marker that
you're interested in and i guess you're
asking about fox9 and then just have
that two cell populations
defined so
yeah
all right well thank you angeline and
victor do you have any final comments
for our audience
i
don't really have anything except you
know it's a it's it's been a a very good
learning journey personally and that
yeah that's what victor has said it's
you don't have to be afraid of
the data
yeah and uh i would like to also add
that
i've forgotten to mention one piece term
here is that when you using high content
phenotypic approaches
you are actually tackling the biological
question with a very holistic view of
what is happening within the cell
and that's tremendously important
because i just remembered uh when i was
working
back as a graduate student and my my
supervisor would always emphasize
that you always have to took science in
a holistic integrated holistic view of
everything so that you can better study
what is happening in this system you can
just you know just be
very narrow disable example just looking
at one specific signaling pathway and
see how that responsible you'd be great
if you can look at you know other things
that are happening within yourself in
addition to
a compartment that you're interested in
and so uh i just wanted to want to keep
that in mind
if you are interested in more integrated
more holistic theories opposed to cell
biology
this would be your best bet
all right well thank you again angeline
and victor for your time today we would
also like to thank labyrinths and our
sponsor molecular devices for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye
you